Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Prittlove und heute ist es soweit,
die 1hundert. Folge von UKW geht über den Tisch. Ich bin ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen
überrascht, wie schnell das ging, aber äh es gab einfach ausreichend Krisen, über die es sich zu berichten lohnte und äh na ja, das habt ihr alle mitbekommen, ähm dann hat sich das einfach so ergeben und insofern bin ich eigentlich auch
ganz froh, diese Marke erreicht zu haben, auch wenn natürlich Zahlen irgendwie auch nur.
Und Rauch sind, aber heute äh machen wir's auch ganz klassisch und tauchen nochmal in äh die Brexit-Sager äh ein und ich begrüße natürlich den John. Hallo.
Hallo hallo und wie viele UKWs haben wir zum Thema Brexit gemacht, schon äh schon einige bisher.
Ist jetzt der elfte.
Okay, gut. Zehn Prozent von der der.
Hat's äh dann sozusagen mitgerissen. Ja aber äh trotzdem in mittlerweile äh auch glaube ich ein ganz schönes äh Protokoll des Ganzen äh Geschehens. Ich weiß gar nicht, wann haben wir denn überhaupt angefangen ähm,
Nochmal selber nachschauen ähm also es ging los.
Teil 1 äh hoppsala ähm.
Neunzehn, Februar zwanzig neunzehn, also wir sind jetzt auch schon seit drei Jahren äh dabei. Ja und seitdem ist ja einiges passiert.
So und jetzt ist wieder was passiert und deswegen dachten wir uns beide gleich
so, okay, alles klar, jetzt ist äh der Zeitpunkt wieder äh gekommen. Alle werden's mitbekommen haben, Boris Johnson ist zurückgetreten als
Ja, Chef der Torries, nicht als Premierminister, das eine äh Besonderheit in in äh Großbritannien, auf die wir auch noch eingehen werden. Ich hatte jetzt übrigens auch gerade wieder ein kleines äh Mini-Brexit äh Erlebnis, weil ich irgendwie
versucht habe aus London Gatwick äh wieder zurück nach Deutschland zu fliegen und ähm ja der Personalmangel scheint also auch die Flughäfen mittlerweile voll erwischt zu haben
und der Flughafen war dann nicht in der Lage äh den ganzen Andrang noch zur äh händeln. Ich saß im Flugzeug und.
Der Flug wurde mir sozusagen unter dem Hintern weg gecancelt weil einfach nicht genug Personal da war, um irgendwie die Koffer 1 ähFlugzeug zu laden.
So na ja.
Aber aber offiziell nach der Linie von Boris Johnson, Corona ist in Großbritannien vorbei. Äh also Hoher, du hast es genau erlebt, wie wie Großbritannien noch sehr hart betroffen ist von von Corona. Also ähm da.
Ja aber ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das jetzt so eine Corona-Auswirkung war, ist es halt die gesamt das Gesamtpaket. Ich meine, das betrifft ja auch mittlerweile den Rest von Europa, ne, auch was äh.
Ja wenn Großbritannien ist es besonders schwierig, also weil
weil um überhaupt Leute zu rekrutieren in den Flughäfen. Es ist noch schwieriger, weil die sind ja besonders in London. Die ernten von Jobs, die
Normaleweise Leute aus anderen Ländern der EU getan haben bis Brexit und die Fluglinien können Leute diese Leute nicht mehr rekrutieren. Also dass ähm das macht alles noch schwieriger in Großbritannien.
Genau, den Eindruck äh hatte ich auch und ähm ja, dementsprechend muss ich drunter äh leiden, aber einen Tag später konnte ich dann endlich das Land verlassen. Ich war.
Ganz froh, dass ich wieder weg war. Ja ähm wo haben wir denn aufgehört? Wir waren
das letzte Mal hier beisammen, Anfang November letzten Jahres und haben äh vor allem zurückgeblickt auf die ganzen
realen Auswirkungen der nun final eintretenden neuen Regelungen und die Lieferschwierigkeit, Lieferketten, Problematik, die ja mittlerweile eben auch den Rest Europas auch erreicht hat, aber der halt in UK
viel früher heftiger eingesetzt hat und noch sehr schwieriger zu lösen ist. Ähm keine Ahnung wie sich das mittlerweile so eingeruckelt hat.
Ja, also die Diskussion in Großbritannien ist.
Es geht nicht um die Brexit-Auswirkung, sondern mehr diese nach Coronazeit besonders äh Lebensmittelpreisen und Energiepreisen,
Das betrifft Deutschland besonders hart.
Weil Großbritannien nicht mehr im europäischen Energiemarkt dabei ist, also
Es gibt steigende Energiekosten hier in Deutschland, aber deutlich höheren äh Steigerungen in Großbritannien?
Die direkte Brexit-Auswirkungen waren ab und zu spürbar, so großen LKW-Schlangen an den Häfen, ähm aber das ist hm das spielt nicht die.
Eine sehr große Rolle in die öffentliche Batze.
Zurzeit in Großbritannien. Also es gibt so eine Reihe von Krisen, dass die die direkt im ähm Brexit bezogene Krisen sind eher geringer. Aber auch sehr sehr wichtig und interessant.
Vor ein paar Wochen heraus die wirtschaftlichen Zahlen aus Großbritannien und es gibt nur zwei Regionen, die dann den wirtschaftlichen Stand von,
vor der Finanzkrise erreicht haben, ja? So es gab so eine tiefe Periode, lange Periode von von langsames Wachstum in Großbritannien.
Krise von.
Also und diese Regionen sind dann London und nur die Irland, ja, also weil
in den letzten paar Jahren, also die die das einzige Region in Großbritannien, wo es ordentliches Wirtschaftswachstum gab, war dann Nordirland, weil die sind von dem Brexit
am wenigsten hart betroffen. Ähm also und äh ja das ist ja ziemlich interessant und dann sind dann die Regionen besonders im Norden Englands
die noch am härtesten betroffen sind und dann wir erinnern uns dann an dem an dem Unterhaus 20 19, wo Boris Johnson einen enormen Stimmen äh gewonnen hat in genau diese Regionen, die dann
dann äh wirtschaftlich zur Zeit leiden. Also das ein bisschen nur den Hintergrund. Ähm aber das ist nicht nicht mehr in den Schlagzeilen wirklich seit seit November.
Denn in den Schlagzeilen seit äh November äh ist vor allem ja das Partyleben der äh der Eliten in äh Großbritannien und speziell der äh Regierung, Stichwort Partygate.
Auf einmal äh gab es Berichte über
Partys, die gefeiert wurden so in Regierungskreisen Behörden, Government-Kreisen äh während der Coronazeit zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo die härtesten Auflagen.
Gemacht wurden und äh die waren ja auch nicht ohne in Großbritannien.
Ja und das hat dann natürlich wenig überraschend für eine ganze Menge Aufschrei gesorgt, weil während halt alle anderen sich irgendwie zu Hause eingesperrt haben. Da sind die da halt alle im Garten und.
Gefeiert.
Und dass wir dann nicht nur ein paar Mal. Das Wolfgang eine Riesenreihe von Partys, die in in in Darningstreet ähm äh stattgefunden haben.
Die die ersten Gerüchte kamen aus äh äh am dreißig. November raus in The Daily Mira also the Daily Mira hat hier eine sehr entscheidende Rolle als als ähm ähm als Zeitung gespielt. Die haben vom Beginn an.
Dieses ganze Reihe von Parties untersucht, besonders die Chef äh Korrespondentin People Pepe hat
alles alles so alles unter die äh ähm äh so so gesetzt und dann es kam natürlich dann da raus dann ob's dann Fragen,
im Unterhaus zu äh an Boris Johnson was passierte und wann und am Beginn hat er gesagt
soweit ich weiß, haben wir zu jedem Zeitpunkt alle Regeln respektiert. Und dann kamen immer mehr Informationen raus, Bilder raus mit Flaschen Bier und Wein und so weiter und es war dann doch klar.
Äh die haben überhaupt die Regeln überhaupt nicht respektiert, ja, die kamen aus einem ähm äh Supermarkt an an, die haben ähm so riesen Taschen voller Alkohol reingenommen, aber
grundsätzlich, was auch sehr hier sehr wichtig ist, ist nicht nur wo Boris Johnson arbeitet,
sondern wo er auch wohnt. Also es gibt dann eine Wohnung da und Boris Johnson's Frau äh Carrie hat auch dann Freunden da eingeladen.
So es ist eine Art geschütztes Bereich
wo man wohnt und lebt und das bedeutet, dass wenn man so was gemacht hätte, woanders, vielleicht käme dann
ganze Gerüchten so schon früher raus. Ähm aber das war dann auch eine Begründung, warum es dann so lange gedauert hat, bis wir dann dann alles ähm äh rausgefunden haben.
Aber dann in Wien in alle Sachen Mc Boris Johnson, weil er nicht klar und ehrlich war in seine Reaktionen,
auf Partygate hatte dann diese Situation für sich selber dann schwieriger gemacht. Also am Beginn hatte dann ähm Simon Case gefragt. Der Simon Case ist der,
so Chef der der Behörden dass da so der ja ähm.
Gefragt. Also da ist dann ein Beamter. Könnte er dann bitte diese Situation in Downing Street dann untersuchen. So eine eine Art,
unabhängige Untersuchung. Aber
das war dann nicht mehr möglich, weil Case es kam raus, dass Case selber bei einige von den Festen dabei war.
Er soll da, die haben dann eine Ternitive dann gefunden. Sie hieß also sie kam aus einer anderen andere Ministerium und musste dann in einen Bericht erfassen zu dieser ganzen Partygate
Aber das war dann auch für Zörgert, weil dann alles was, was dann in den Dely Mira erschien, war so ernsthaft.
Dass die mussten dann eine polizeiliche Untersuchung dann beginnen mit dem Metropolitan Police.
Und dann Cugrey könnte dieses Bericht dann nicht rausbringen war dann den Spruch während dem dem kompletten Frühling weil die das dann alles dann untersucht haben.
Aber natürlich dann die matchboilischen Police-Untersuchung war dann verzögert wegen,
die Wahlen in Nordirland und auch lokalen Wahlen in in England. Die haben gesagt, das können wir nicht raus jetzt nicht rausbringen, weil es steht ein ein Wahlkurz vor.
So alles verdammt dann verzögert und dann kam dem Match in please ähm ähm Untersuchung dann raus. Ähm Boris Johnson, den Finanzminister, damaligen Finanzminister Synak,
und äh Boris Johnson Frau Carrie, die haben ähm ähm die müssen Strafen bezahlen, weil es es war dann klar, dass die haben dann die die coronaregeln,
nicht respektiert. Und dann kam dann diese,
raus mit einer anderen Reihe von vom vom problematischen Fällen diese diversen Partys.
Karioki Maschinen, äh tanzen in den in den ähm äh Untergeschoss von Downing Street, Partys in den Garten und so weiter und so fort.
Aber am das ganze Partygate so war so eine lange und.
Sie mich schon nervige Geschichte? Also man wusste nicht.
Haben wir jetzt, kennen wir alle Fakten jetzt, ja? Ähm weil es gab so viele diversen Quellen. Ähm aber am Ende.
Das vierte nicht direkt zu dem Sturz von Boris Johnson. Ja also das vierte so eine allgemeine.
Unzufriedenheit mit ihm, den Eindruck, dass er erinnert sich selber an den Regeln nicht.
Ähm aber es gab dann anderen Problemen, die dann direkt den ähm äh so Ende von Boris Johnson führt.
Es zog jetzt ja ewig in die Länge und vor allem äh man hat ja immer so den Eindruck, immer, immer wenn er gerade wieder äh sich eine neue Lüge ausgedacht hat, wie man das dann doch wieder machen kann und so ein paar Antworten sind ja auch mittlerweile ikonisch so als Work-Event.
Genau, ja, ja, genau, genau, ja, ja.
Und immer wenn dann gerade wieder Ruhe eingekehrt war, kamen wieder neue Fotos raus, die also alles widerlegt haben, was bisher sozusagen ja ach ja das, na ja gut, also.
Union, hier ist eine Flasche Wein in wo ich normalerweise arbeite
ich hatte so Probleme mit der Trennung von Arbeit und meine Freizeit während Krone. Wie so viele von uns, hey Moment mal. Ja ähm ähm
Ja, es war äh einfach so rumsünder. Ja, aber wir sind jetzt, wir haben diese dieses Krieg in der Ukraine. Jetzt ist nicht der Zeit der Premierminister zu besetzen. Wir
brauchen Zeit, ja? Und es wäre keine Zeit, dann die Regierung jetzt zu wechseln, weil wir sind überhaupt in der wir sind so gut in der Lage gute Entscheidungen zu,
Moment mal, ne? Ähm.
Hattest du denn den Eindruck, dass sich die Rolle der Medien ein bisschen äh verändert hat? Weil ich meine, die Medien haben ja nun dieses ganze Tor-Regime eigentlich auch und den Brexit auch weit
die Bevölkerung reingetragen und mitgetragen, so es gibt natürlich auch Ausnahmen, aber äh Daily Mirror zum Beispiel, wie würdest du den politisch äh so.
Aber links ja also die waren
nie so sehr großen Boris Johnson Fans. Ähm was hier dann entscheidend war, finde ich, waren die die Rolle von,
Einige Journalisten bei anderen Zeitungen, also besonders The Times hat grundsätzlich,
eher rechts, aber am Ende, die haben auch doch den Punkt erreicht. Also so so kann es nicht weitergehen. Ähm also das bedeutet
Daily Mira hat das so wirklich begonnen und ernsthaft äh sich mit mit diesen Themen der kompletten Partygate beschäftigst. Aber am Ende es waren
nur noch so Daily Mail und
und schützen Boris Johnson halbwegs. Also es waren dann the Times und einige Journalisten auch von The Telegraph, die gesagt, hey Moment mal, so kann es einfach nicht weitergehen. Also
das dann haben wir dann gesehen, he Moment mal, diese so, dass den kompletten so Spektrum, so von Mitte bis rechts die die eigentlich dann Boris Johnson durch viel unterstützt haben, besonders durch Corona, das ging dann nicht weiter, also das das hat
doch dann äh zu dem Sulemente von Boris Johnson geführt.
Okay, also da hat sich das sozusagen schon abgezeichnet, dass quasi die Geduld äh des Konservativen Establishments mit seinen äh einfach
an ein Ende kam.
Genau, genau, genau da.
Ja, also Partygate, das hat sich dann noch weiter äh entwickelt über die ganze Zeit. Wie gesagt, es kamen halt immer wieder Sachen raus, aber es sind ja dann auch noch äh andere Sachen ähm passiert. Politisch
kam ja dann vor allem die Diskussion um dieses nasan Island Agreement mit der EU, also Teil dieses ähm
des Austrittsvertrages, der halt konkret regelt, was der Status von Nordirland ist, haben wir ja eben schon erwähnt, Nordirland ist sozusagen wirtschaft
bevorteilt, weil sie ja nach wie vor am EU-Markt teilnehmen können und an dem ähm eine Zollffreiheit und von daher halt äh normal Handel treiben können und das ja dann.
Auch, aber auch noch mit UK machen können. Also die sozusagen Best of both Worlds haben, trotz alledem gibt es ja diese spezielle.
Grenzregelung zwischen Nordirland und UK, um einfach zu verhindern, dass jetzt UK quasi durch Nordirland Waren in die EU reinschleust und deswegen muss es ja da spezielle ähm
Ja, Überprüfungen geben, Kontrollen geben et cetera.
Ja ja.
Genau und das ist ja so ein bisschen so der der der Zankapfel äh gewesen, obwohl, ich meine, Sie haben's ja unterschrieben. Also ich meine, es war sozusagen das, was ja
sonst selber meinte, was heißt denn der der tollste Vertrag seit.
Und der Overn-Ready Brexit-Deal hatte das ja beschrieben in zwanzig 1neun, ja ja.
Aber man muss ja immer irgendwas haben, wo man gegen die EU hackt und dann kam halt permanent so diese ganze Diskussion auf mit. Das wäre ja unfair und überhaupt und,
ja gar nicht und das müsste man jetzt wieder auflösen und ich habe immer so den Eindruck gehabt, so die EU, die sah so aus der Ferne hat sich das so angeschaut und dachte so Leute, das nicht euer Ernst oder? Und im.
Wenn es wieder richtig laut wurde und jetzt machen wir das aber auch wirklich, hat sich dann so die EU etwas ähm deutlicher geäußert so zwischendurch, so nach dem Motto ähm könnt ihr einfach mal total vergessen, wenn da äh irgendwas kommt, das wird,
gut enden. Aber das war ja sozusagen auch gar nicht das Ziel, sondern es war ja eigentlich immer nur um diese innenpolitische,
Debatte zu befeuern, um irgendwie so einen Konflikt zu haben, wo die EU in irgendeiner Form als was Böses dargestellt wird, damit äh sich nicht alle Leute auf Boris Johnson konzentrieren.
Aber es gab eine Periode zwischen Mitte Dezember und März grob als es dann aussah
Es könnte doch noch ein bisschen besser gehen, also ein bisschen stabiler oder oder einen besseren Verhältnissen wären, dann möglich, weil der ehemalige Brexit-Minister äh David Frost ist
18. Dezember so getreten und der hat eine deutlich hetere Linie von Boris Johnson,
gewünscht damals und der ist dann zurückgedrängt und sagt, hey Moment mal so, ich kriege keine Rückendeckung von Boris Johnson für meine sehr harte Linie in Richtung Brüssel. Ich trete hier zurück.
Und dann dann also die die jetzige damalige und so war sogar auch die jetzige äh Außenministerin, hat dann,
Die Verantwortung für Beziehungen mit Brüssel dann übernommen
und am Beginn war es alles ziemlich friedlich, also nette so äh aber auf Instagram gepostet von also die Königin von Instagram in in den britischen System,
ähm zusammen mit mit der der Vizepräsident der europäischen Mission und.
Trussa zu signalisieren, ja, wir wir wollen pragmatische Lösungen und so weiter. Aber dann,
Die Situation hat sich so dann wieder verschärft April, besonders April, Anfang Mai. Weil dann am 6. Mai fand dann
Novan Islandly Elections statt. Und warum war das dann
dann äh so so problematisch, weil die Partei der ausgehende,
Premiere Minister Nordirlands, den den ähm ähm Junioristen aus der Unionisten DJ.
Mochte nie diese Sondelösung für Nordirland und die haben dann gesagt,
okay, wenn wir dann gewinnen, wir wollen den nordirischen Protokoll.
Verhandeln, ja, dass dass Notirland eine engere Verbindung mit dem restlichen Großbritannien.
Erhaben muss und eine fanere Beziehung zu Irland. Aber diese komplette Problematik, dann führte dann zu,
so Stimmverluste für den DOP, stimmt Gewinne für einen
unabhängigen Partei, also den Partei, also nicht nationalistisch, nicht jungistisch
Und dann am Ende, obwohl die doch nicht so viel an Stimmen gewonnen haben, dann kam nach der nach der Wahl als größte Partei bei der Notirischens raus, also dann
die ähm äh die Nationalisten,
Das bedeutet dann, dann das wirfte dann ein Schatten auf den komplett diese komplette Situation. Was könnte London dann
von Brüssel verlangen, was dann akzeptabel wäre,
für die und das ist dann den jetzigen Stand. Also wir wir haben keine Lösung in sich,
Es kam dann ein ein Gesetzentwurf Anfang Juni raus. Das Großbritannien,
will einfach mal sagen hey wir wollen eine komplett neue Beziehung in Nordirland das ist was wir machen wollen und falls die EU das nicht für uns tut dann
wir respektieren halt, was wir vor zwei Jahren und und und unterschrieben haben
Und das ist dann dem jetzigen Stand. Also dann dieses Vorschlag nervte Brüssel ganz viel.
Wir respektieren oder wir respektieren das nicht.
Ist nicht mehr, ja? Ähm wir werden dann einfach mal die Kontrollen, die erforderlich sind, an den Fähren für den Import von Waren. Wir werden einfach mal diese diese Kontrollen einfach nicht ausführen.
Ähm und Brustso sagte, okay, also wir wir stellen wir müssen alles juristisch überprüfen, Busse blieb vorerst.
Ziemlich ruhig, ja, aber Brüssel wusste auch, dass die die Zeit, die noch,
Johnson noch im Armt bleiben wird.
Muss begrenzt sein. Ja, also das bedeutet, dass am Ende Brüssel kann ruhig bleiben, weil die mittelfristigere Linie der britische Region ist nicht klar, ja weil das bedeutet, dass
Es war mehr ein also äh also Trus haben dann.
Zwei Spielen gleichzeitig gespielt. Erstens wie mache wie macht man etwas für den Nordirischen.
Und auf der anderen Seite wie gewinne man an Unterstützung parteiintern für eine zukünftige.
Wahl für die Nachfolge von Boris Johnson. Also eine gute Beziehung mit Brüssel war nie oder nee vielleicht ein bisschen anders. Am Beginn dachte Februar dieses Jahr eine bessere Beziehung mit Brüssel,
wäre möglich, weil sie ist grundsätzlich jetzt sage ich nicht pro europäisch, aber.
Sie ist nicht blöd, ja? Sie versteht, dass Großbritannien braucht einen ordentlichen Beziehung mit Brüssel. Aber sie will nicht nur Außenminister bleiben, sondern sie will auch
setzen und das ist dann den Grund.
Für die immer härtere Linie in Sachen notirisches Protokoll von. Es ist nicht eine persönliche Glaube, sondern ein taktisches Spiel um den Parteivorsitz
äh dann zu gewinnen.
Also man muss ja auch sagen, List Russ war seinerzeit Remana. Genau. Relativ.
Uns zählt zu den zu den härtesten Brexiteers jetzt. Hat eigentlich noch dazu gesagt, okay
wir ich muss jetzt die Leute überzeugen, dass ich jetzt so wirklich so ein real believer bin, ja ähm und das ist was, was sie jetzt vorantreibt.
Wir werden gleich nochmal zu ihr kommen, weil äh sie ja jetzt auch eine der Kandidatinnen ist für die Nachfolge von Boris Johnson. Ähm aber bleiben wir vielleicht nochmal kurz in Nordirland. Du hast es ja schon erwähnt. Es gab diese Wahl, also die Semly in äh Nordirland, das ähm,
Wolf Parliment, also sozusagen die die äh regionale äh Regierung, die aber schon immer das Problem hatte, dass sie sich äh schwer einig werden konnte, weil es gibt ja einerseits durch das Nordirland-Abkommen, durch das Good Friday Agreement, ist fest.
Quasi die Regierung immer von den beiden rechts und links stehenden, also von oder von den Unionisten.
Ja rechts und links trifft's da äh überhaupt nicht. Die sitzen wahrscheinlich auch irgendwo rechts und links, aber das ist jetzt nicht das normale politische Spektrum, sondern hat die Unionisten, also die, die sozusagen die Union mit Großbritannien,
in ihrem Herzen äh tragen, die halt auch vor allem der ähm äh religiösen äh der nicht katholischen.
Protestantischen Teil äh äh sozusagen sich zugehörig fühlen und auf der anderen Seite eben die katholische.
Äh die eben republikanisch orientiert sind, die also quasi schon immer für eine Einheit mit mit Irland
äh sozusagen sich positioniert haben, und dann halt eben auch sozusagen in ihrer Geschichte mit dem ganzen Terror auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise auch immer äh verbunden war, immer so als politischer Arm äh der IAA galt. So und jetzt
kam diese Wahlen und durch diese Verschiebung weg von den Unionisten, hin zu der Lions Party.
Dadurch gelang es eigentlich erst, dass erste Mal eine mehr also nicht eine Mehrheit hatte, sondern die stärkste Partei wurde.
Ja, genau und das bedeutet, dass dann die So Premierministerin wird dann von Shine sein, aber zur Zeit,
Es wird keine Regierung geben, ne, so kein Powersharing Agreement. Ähm weil den den ähm Unionisten, also die nehmen dann,
an eine Regierung bis dann die aus der Sicht der DP die benötigte Änderungen,
Protokoll kriegen. Ja, aber also ja versteht so ziemlich blöd. Die haben eine Unterstützung verloren, aber auf
beiden Seiten, also an den Pragmatisten von den A Lions Party, also die Partei, die wollen einfach mal weg von diese so alte Kluft den beiden so traditionellen religiösen äh Gruppen im im im Notirischen so
Politik und wollen dann einfach so sagen, hey Moment mal, so wir gehören alle hier zusammen. Wir wollen gute, ordentliche wirtschaftliche Lösungen äh für für Nordirland. Die hier haben eine Unterstützung dann gewonnen.
Aber dann Parteien, die dann noch krasser gegen Dublin, ja, so noch stärker.
Für die Union mit Großbritannien sind, haben auch einige Stimmen von den ähm äh gewonnen. Also die haben dann,
beiden Seiten an Stimmen ein bisschen etwas verloren. Also die stehen in eine sehr problematische Situation. Aber die sind ja auch zum Teil selber schuld, weil
Es war ja blöd, weil die waren für den EU-Austritt.
Ganz am Anfang. Die haben auch einen EU-Austritt unterstützt damals, obwohl die EU-Ausschnitt gefördert worden von Tresa May wäre besser für für
politisch für Nordirland aus dem jetzt aus dem jetzigen von Boris Johnson. Also was bedeutet? Die haben
nie verstanden, dass Großbritannien in der EU.
War eine gute Sache für Notirland wäre, ja. Das haben die nie kapiert und kapieren die immer noch nicht. Also was bedeutet, man hat jetzt so eine Art.
Man man sieht äh man hat keine Lösung in sich da politisch in Nordirland. So die Situation ist so irgendwie so eingefroren bis,
Die Situation an eine andere ist in London und und wir wir müssen bis Herbst dieses Jahr warten, bis wir dann wissen, wie ist die politische Lage in London und,
und dann ist Westminster überhaupt diese Änderungen des nordirischen Protokolls überhaupt dann durchführen. Ähm aber das ist dann dem jetzigen Stand. Also alles ist so blockiert, also eingefroren aber.
Immer noch Ruhe ist. Also es gibt kein die kein so wie die Kehrung von von von Terrorismusgefahr zur Zeit, ja?
Wie ist denn das ähm hast du da so einen Blick dafür, wie das so in Irland aufgenommen wird? Wie wie blickt die Republik Irland auf diese Situation?
Es ist ein bisschen schwierig, waren auch Shinpain, gewinnt auch in Dublin zurzeit an an Unterstützung. Aber Irland hat auch.
Angst, also Not-Irland ist im Vergleich zu zu Irland immer noch deutlich ärmer.
Politische Lage wird auch beim Vereinigtes Irland nicht unbedingt einfacher ja also dann eine Aufnahme Nordirlands so oder ein vereintes Irland
ist auch dann für Dublin ziemlich problematisch. Also es ist ja politisch wichtig für äh für ähm die Regierung in in Dublin, dass,
man man das diese jetzige Notirische Protokoll dann noch.
Wirkt und noch funktioniert, weil das das hilft ihr Land auch natürlich. Ähm aber zur Zeit, die haben ja, die haben ja Angst politisch in. Kann ich auch durchaus verstehen und was auch.
Bisher ziemlich gut war oder ziemlich ähm ich mochte das wirklich. Dublin hat.
Immer noch enorm viel politische Unterstützung aus anderen Ländern der EU. Also das bedeutet, die EU blieb hinter Dublin vereint. Aber wenn groß, wenn.
Großbritannien.
Zerstört jetzt die notirischen Protokoll und es gäbe dann Spannungen an der irische Notirische Grenze.
Wie weit geht dann diese Unterstützung?
Dem restlichen EU für Eheland, ja? Falls es wirklich so unkontrollierte Produkte von England nach Nordirland und dann in Irland hineinkommt und dann in den Binnenmarkt was kann die,
EU doch am Ende doch noch akzeptieren, ja? Und ginge und gingen dann Spannungen zwischen Irland und anderen Ländern der EU dann los. Also das passierte bisher nicht, aber das ist.
Es könnte so diese Situation mittelfristig kommen.
Ja? Aber natürlich die EU kennt Großbritannien unter Druck setzen und sagen hey Moment mal sorry das geht nicht wirtschaftlich das geht nicht politisch, das geht nicht
Ähm also lasst uns mal wieder ans ans Verhandlungstisch kommen äh und sehen wir, was wir dann dann lösen können. Aber ob das überhaupt möglich,
ist dann von den die politische Situation in in in Westminster dann 100 Prozent abhängig.
Und natürlich auch in der EU, weiß man ja nicht, was ich bis dahin noch äh ändert, aber grundsätzlich habe ich schon so den Eindruck, dass ähm.
Sollte also jetzt wirklich UK auf die Idee kommen, das so als Druckmittel einzusetzen und so ein bisschen so hier äh ihr habt jetzt katastrophale Zustände äh äh so äh seht ihr, was ihr davon habt?
Ist ja nicht so, dass die EU keinen Druckmittel hätte, weil natürlich grade die äh der Ärmelkanal, äh da lässt sich natürlich beliebig viel verschärfen so in ähm bestimmten Maße natürlich. Ähm von daher ja bin ich da.
Sehe ich eigentlich die EU immer noch am längeren Hebel, aber dass das zu.
Ja ja, aber aber die aber die beiden die beiden Seiten wollen oder sollen keinen Handelsstreit wollen, ja? Äh die die EU versteht das und.
Bleib ruhig und versuche das zu vermeiden. Aber was wir Großbritannien als Land wohnen.
Lebt irgendwie noch in dieser Art.
So was ist die Realität ja und wie macht man einen Erfolg aus Brexit, ja also wir wir haben jetzt die wirtschaftlichen Zahlen. So die Frage ist,
wann erreicht Großbritannien, so dieses so tiefste Punkt, wo man beginnt mal wieder.
So nach auf der Realität.
Irgendwie so zu kehren. Und dieses Punkt hat Großbritannien bisher nicht erreicht. Also das bedeutet könnte man den den Boris Johnson artiger ja
also wir haben hier Recht, also wir wir wir tun was wir wollen, ja, dass,
beschädigt Großbritannien und und äh und verschärft noch die schon problematische, wirtschaftliche Situation, aber,
Wäre es noch möglich, dass das Großbritannien genau das noch einmal mache? Ich kann es nicht ausschließen.
Also viele Einschätzungen, ich habe mich dir auch angeschlossen, äh waren ja so nach dem Brexit-Referendum so,
Das dauert jetzt erstmal ein Jahrzehnt, bis sich dieses Land irgendwie so weit gedreht hat, weil die Erfahrungen müssen alle erstmal gemacht und eingearbeitet werden und dann muss man auch den Leuten genug Zeit geben, äh die Realität nicht nur zu akzeptieren, sondern es ist auch öffentlich zu.
So ja äh und von daher ähm haben wir glaube ich noch ein paar Jahre.
Ja dann das wird und auch von Label. Man hört nichts. Ja also man man sagt Brexit, man dieses Wort oder
irgendwas zum Thema bessere Verbindung mit ähm Beziehungen mit der EU darf man nicht sagen. Also also als wichtigste Oppositionspartei
rennen weit weit noch von von die von von von dieses Thema.
Aber die Dinge äh gehen ja weiter in der Welt und dann äh kam es zum Krieg in der Ukraine und ähm das war natürlich jetzt auch wieder ein äh interessantes äh Ding, weil natürlich jetzt hier auf einmal die weltpolitische Rolle,
Großbritannien ähm,
Auf einmal wieder auf die Agenda kam, ja, die so bisher ja äh in den letzten Jahren äh wenig eine Rolle gespielt hat denn einerseits ist ja UK zusammen mit USA
offiziell zumindest ja so ein bisschen der Schutzpatron des
der bisherigen äh Regelungen äh Friedens in Anführungsstrichen Friedensregelung zwischen Russland und der Ukraine und.
Müssen Sie sich von daher auch ein wenig in der Pflicht sehen und war dann ganz interessant zu sehen, wie äh man reagiert hat und es ging dann eigentlich relativ schnell. Äh man könnte natürlich jetzt unterstellen, Boris Johnson hat die Gelegenheit geliebt, äh wieder von seinen ganzen Skandalen abzulenken,
aber ich aber ich glaube, es ist halt schon aber auch ähm,
Das ist jetzt so eine so eine so eine Fernewahrnehmung oder vielleicht projiziere ich das auch so ein bisschen, aber ich habe so das Gefühl.
In solchen Momenten erinnert sich der Apparat UK aber auch wieder sozusagen an seine gesamt.
Bedeutung und auch all seine Fähigkeiten. Natürlich kommt jetzt hier auch die militärische äh Rolle ganz stark mit rein. Aber es ist sozusagen auch für das Land ähm,
keine große Schwierigkeit gewesen sich politisch voll gegen Russland zu stellen und hinter die Ukraine zu stellen während wir das ja hier in Deutschland ein Eiertanz äh erlebt haben und immer,
erleben, der äh sehr, sehr schwierig zu erklären äh ist, der sicherlich auch seine Gründe hat, aber eben äh dort einfach ganz anders aussah. Und da gab's halt auch mal wieder so einen schönen Feind und äh man konnte mal wieder sein Militär äh ausrollen
und hat auch sehr schnell für Unterstützung ähm zur Unterstützung geführt, zu konkreter Unterstützung geführt, die auch viel geholfen hat bisher.
Ähm einerseits, andererseits.
Die Flüchtlingswelle, die dann äh aus der Ukraine in Richtung äh Westen gerollt ist, die ist dann halt mal wieder auf dem Kontinent verteilt worden. Aber am Ärmelkanal.
Also.
Da war dann Schluss.
Ja, aber aber aber das ist dann tippisch für Großbritannien. Ja ähm also und und Boris Johnson hat hat das auch so
braucht, um um seine Position zu verteidigen, ja? Also jetzt Schluss mit dem kompletten Party-Gate-Skandal, also wir sind mitten in einem Krieg und wir unterstützen der Ukraine, ja? Also was er selber da getan hat,
also ich erwarte
gar keine Änderung der Linie in Richtung und Waffenlieferung und so. Von aller anderen möglichen Boris Johnson Nachfolger, also es gab da einen totalen
Kompromiss parteiintern bei den konservativen, aber eine volle Unterstützung von Labour. Also man liefere Waffen, Großbritannien hat.
Diese komplette, so Spannungen, was wir in Deutschland haben oder in Italien mit Gaslieferungen. Also.
Großbritannien hat keine Sorgen, einfach mal zu sagen, okay, wir schicken Waffen. Ja, also es ist wird.
Niemand in die britische Debatte hat so gesagt hey Moment mal also pass auf wir wollen nicht dass es wirklich da schief geht ähm von einem Tag bis zum nächsten also das könnte man ohne ohne große Sorge dann dann machen.
Man hatte dann diese diese Periode so Ende Februar Anfang März als dann die Situation war dann in Richtung Brüssel dann auch,
Etwas lockerer, also Deutschland und Frankreich in anderen Ländern der EU waren auch dann ganz happy, dass.
Boris Johnson in der Lage war.
Britische Waffen an der Ukraine zu liefern, ja? Weil das das machte dann das Arbeit für Short zum Beispiel, ein bisschen einfacher, so Ukraine hatte ausreichend oder,
nicht ausreichen, aber hatte doch einige Waffen ähm Waffenlieferungen äh gekriegt von von Johnson. Also man hat gesehen, wenn eine kurze Periode.
Es war ein bisschen,
ruhiger, so geopolitisch die die Situation zwischen Großbritannien und die anderen Länder der EU. Aber ja, das ist ein grundsätzliches Verhalten in Großbritannien. Also so so was kann man ohne,
ohne großes Streit ähm findet man in Unterstützung für sowas. Ähm innerhalb dem innerhalb von den Systemen.
Ja also Militär hat einfach auch eine ganz andere Rolle in der in der britischen äh Gesellschaft. Ich kann mich noch erinnern.
Schottland war, dann habe ich mich auch so mit Schotten über ihr Verhältnis äh zu England erhalten, was ja noch nie besonders gut war so und irgendwie irgendwie hasst ihr euch so, aber.
Wenn dann irgendwie hier Krieg ist so damals ging's glaube ich um die.
Man meint so ja, so wie komisch, wenn wenn Krieg ausbricht.
Dann sind wir irgendwie alle wieder eins. So, dann ist es schon wirklich auch als als Nation sozusagen und und nicht mehr die einzelnen Regionen so richtig gut erklären, warum das so ist, konnten sie mir auch.
Aber das aber diese Aversion gegen äh die Aufnahme von von Flüchtlingen so. Ich meine, das hat ja nun den ganzen Brexit dominiert
das war ja so einer der Kernpunkte, diese dieser rassistische äh Unterton, der immer drin war bis hin zu.
1 zu eins Kopien von alten Nazi äh Plakaten mit der Überflutung und so weiter, nicht wahr? Haben wir ja alles gesehen. Dann gab's aber dann noch eine sehr ähm ja eine sehr.
Schwierige Regelung, die sie sich dann ausgedacht haben in Zusammenhang mit Ruanda.
Ja genau, also dann dann ähm Flüchtlinge, dann so ähm na nach Ruanda zu fliegen. Ähm aber.
Also der Deal war man hat mit Ruanda ein Abkommen ausgehandelt, dass wenn jetzt.
Asylsuchende in UK äh ins Land wollen, dass man sie stattdessen nach Ruanda schickt und dort wird dann ihr Fall geprüft und wenn ihr Asylgesuch sozusagen zugesagt wird, dann dürfen sie bleiben,
Aber in Ruanda.
Da, ja genau, ja, ja. Und wenn wenn es nicht erfolgreich ist, die müssen dann irgendeinen Weg finden von Ruanda, hinzu, keine Ahnung wo, ja.
Ist denn das? Also was ich meine erstmal was was hat Roanda davon?
Ja also aber hat hat Geld von Großbritannien.
Dafür gekriegt, ja. Das das Ganze ist ist weil die die jetzige Innenministerin Pretty Partie ist und den so härtesten überhaupt in in der Regierung will
eigentlich dann Leute zu total abschrecken, also will das niemandem versucht, na, Großbritannien.
Zu kommen. Also das ist dann auch eine.
So so eine Art Widerspruch, diese so Global Briten. Ja, man will so Militäreinsätze, man will offiziell auf Papier so gute Verbindungen mit ehemaliger ähm ähm
Kolonien jetzt in den aber hey Moment mal ja ihr müsst alle da bleiben also versucht doch nicht nach nach Großbritannien äh zu kommen und dieses Art dann Leute möglichst viel so
abzuschrecken, also versucht das doch nicht, führte dann zu diese diese verrückte
ähm äh Politik der der Regierung. Also Juristen haben dann,
die ersten Abschiebungen,
So, die haben Klagen eingereicht und das dann gestoppt. Und es gibt jetzt diese Spielerei gehen dann diese Flüge dann weiter oder oder wie und unter welchen Umständen.
Natürlich also es gibt dann Diskussionen in Großbritannien, aber hauptsächlich geführt durch so in den linken Medien, dass so eine Lösung überhaupt nicht,
sei und vollkommen unakzeptabel ist ähm aber,
Dieses Argument kam bei den bei der konservativen Partei und bei der Regierung überhaupt nicht äh nicht an. Also.
Ich kriege den Eindruck, dass das komplette britische politische System.
Nicht das komplette Bewölkerung, sondern die ganze politische Debatte hat so vollkommen an.
An Menschlichkeit, an an so einen Menschenverstand,
irgendwie so total verloren seit Brexit. Und dann dieses dieses Abschiebungs- äh äh Politik, es ist ein Beweis davon.
Ja, aber das gilt jetzt noch.
Gilt jetzt, aber wir wissen nicht ob oder wann es noch Flüge geben wird nach Wonder sehen wir.
Weil die sind ja die, die gestartet werden sollten, sind ja dann kurzfristig gestoppt worden.
Stoppen ja wegen einem so eine ähm äh juristische Klage ist dann eingereicht worden in den European Court of Human Rights. Äh es gibt so weit ich weiß dann Diskussionen, dann in den nächsten paar Wochen noch ein paar Flüge
Ähm äh dahinzuschicken. Aber auch ja, also.
Die Anzahl an möglichen Abschiebungen sind,
sehr gering, ja? Also es ist böse unmenschlich und funktioniert nicht, ja? Also das ist,
Einwanderungspolitik, ja? Also,
Das ist so typisch an die jetzige Regierung, die wollen beweisen, dass die krass hart rechts sind, aber,
an der Implementierung ist das komplette Ding eine Katastrophe, also das wirkt nicht. Ja und und das ist genau wie in ganz vielen Aspekten das das Land gerade regiert wird.
Ja. Äh aber.
Im Effekt bedeutet das dann für die ukrainischen Flüchtlinge dass man ja Familien nicht zusammenführen konnte oh die woanders unterkommen mussten et cetera also es ist einfach so es ist so ein zynisches äh Verhalten also.
Ja, ja, ja.
Unnötig. Man man könnte das mühelos äh leisten. Ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt Großbritannien auch keinen Bedarf an gut ausgebildeten äh Arbeitskräften hätte.
Ja, also das macht ja auch überhaupt gar keinen Sinn, ne, also äh theoretisch hätten sie ja sogar diese Ukraine-Situation annehmen können und sagen können.
Ach, ganz viele äh Leute, die dringend Arbeit suchen.
Ja, aber aber dieses die komplette ideologische Linie.
Wenn es ja grob eine gibt in Großbritannien, ist einfach mal das dieses.
Diese sehr unmenschliche, sehr harte Linie. Ja, also äh die.
Die Mitteln reichen uns nicht aus irgendwie. Wir können.
Investitionen in das Gesundheitswesen oder Sozialpolitik oder Umbau von Schulen und so weiter das
können wir nicht leisten
irgendwie, ja so in in aller Sachen so so in den internen Politik in Großbritannien. Also das.
Das ist dann diese so harte Linie gegenüber Einwanderer ist auch ein Teil davon. Also ein bisschen so eine Art
unser Mitteln reichen für uns nicht aus. Also und alle diese Leute von außerhalb, die wollen rein, um das noch mehr von uns nehmen oder so
Dealen, ja? Äh und Großbritannien ist so ein
Paradies für Menschen, die dann die alle hierher kommen wollen. Ja das ist nicht der Fall. Also dieses Sozialstaat in Großbritannien, die Standards sind deutlich geringer als in vielen anderen Ländern der D EU.
Beim äh aber das.
Das verstehen die Brücken nicht und und ein und und man sehe zur Zeit kein Weg zurück zu irgendeinem irgendeiner Art ich Hymanistischere oder freundlichere äh.
In Großbritannien. Also ist sehr ja extrem und sehe.
Nasti, ja also ähm ähm nicht nicht nur Einwanderung.
Na ja, aber äh irgendwann ähm hat uns dann das Partygeld auch wieder eingeholt. Die Diskussion um Boris Johnson ging weiter. Ich meine, es ging ja sowieso gefühlt keine Woche, wo nicht wieder irgendein Skandal war, wo er irgendeine
anhinscht Talk gegeben hat, also es gab zahlreiche Beispiele, wo er einfach
Man man sagt ja bei ihm auch immer so hier hieß Rambling und also äh er redet ja auch als ganzer Kommunikationsstil ist ja immer so ein permanentes Ausschütten von einzelnen Worten, die irgendwie so richtig keinen Zusammenhang haben
und in zahlreichen Gelegenheiten hat er einfach äh Reden gehalten. Äh es gab da irgendwie einen Fall, der nochmal besonders aufgefallen ist. Das habe ich jetzt grad nicht mehr in Erinnerung. Weiß nicht, ob du sich da an was erinnerst. Auf jeden.
Diese ich will für drei Terms regieren. Das war das, das war eins von den verrücktesten. Hat so ein Interview gemacht, außer
zwei Nachwahlen verloren hatte, äh ähm.
Das war dann Ende Juni. Das war nur ein paar Wochen her. Ja ich habe die Ansicht Absicht ähm für,
so drei Wahlperioden zu regieren, ja. Echt stand und enorm viel Druck. Ja ja, ich will weithin regieren, ja. Ich so, Moment mal, ist der Typ.
Absolut verrückt. Also das war eins von den übertriebensten ähm äh Dingen die er gesagt hat in den letzten Wochen.
Ja und nicht nur so von den Einzelaussagen, sondern dass einfach auch alles im Zusammenhang einfach überhaupt gar keinen Sinn ergeben hat oder keiner so richtig wusste, was er jetzt eigentlich gerade gesagt hat.
Aber was will er machen? Na ja, er hat nie.
Plan irgendwie, ja. Er hat keine so sage ich treibende Ideologie oder was er für Großbritannien machen will. Er will,
An der Macht bleiben, weil er das er mag das. Aber das ist nicht ausreichend für eine Regierung.
Und ähm
Das haben wir dann äh dann erkannt, ja, also wenn er sagt, ja wir brauchen Stabilität, damit wir unsere Pläne ausführen können hier. Also was sind dann die Pläne? Also ja natürlich haben wir wir haben diese ganze Einwanderungsproblematik,
gesprochen. Aber das ist vom vom vorangetrieben, also nicht von Paris Johnson selber. Ähm also was er machen wollte.
Ist schwer zu erkennen.
Und vor allem häuften sich so die Austritte auch aus seiner äh Regierung immer mehr Leute äh gingen davon ähm und dann gipfelte das Ganze jetzt im,
Ende Juni und Juli mit einer Welle von Austritten ausgelöst durch wieder eine neue ähm Veröffentlichung und diesmal ging's nicht um Partygates, die zehnte, ja da so,
Party geht alleine, hätte nie so richtig gereicht, aber es hat im Prinzip den den Boden bereitet, um sozusagen.
Zu warten so und wenn jetzt noch irgendwas richtig draufknallt, dann dann platzt halt auch den Torries der Kragen, weil man muss ja sagen.
Dass dass die Torries keine keine Scham empfunden haben
Das das ist ja nun wirklich seit Jahren offensichtlich. Denen ist es irgendwo auch egal wer sie regiert und wie regiert wird Hauptsache sie bleiben an der Mach
aber es gab halt jetzt diverse also es sind ja diese Bi-Elections, die meistens dadurch stattfinden, dass was weiß ich, jemand äh stirbt ausm äh Parlament oder.
Muss.
Wegen Skandalen.
Genau wegen wieder irgendwelchen was weiß ich, da gab's ja.
Jene hat so so Poren auf seinem äh Rechner in seinem Büro angeschaut und und äh die haben das bewiesen, dass er das getan hat und musste zurücktreten. Also es kam,
Es gab grundsätzlich drei Etappen, die dann zu dem Sturz von Johnson führten.
Dann diese ähm äh diese ähm äh also die die nach Wahlen,
ähm die am 23. Juni stattgefunden haben in zwei Wahlkreisen, die vorher
wo die Konservativen gewonnen haben in in in Wakefield im im Norden Englands da hat Label gewonnen und Intiviton in Honeton, im Südwesten, also da haben die Liberalen gewonnen. Also das war dann ein wichtiges Punkt,
Ich habe die die Reihenfolge jetzt nicht, ist stimmt nicht. Also dann gab's schon vorher am 6. Juni.
Schon ein parteiinternen Misstrauensvotum
gegen Boris Johnson. Also das kann man bei den konservativen einleiten. Wenn 15 Prozent der Abgeordneten im Parlament nur unter den Konservativen ein Brief
einreichen und sagen, ich habe jetzt kein Vertrauen mehr in den Parteichef und der Parteichef ist dann in Form von Boris Johnson gleichzeitig auch dann der Premierminister. Aber ich habe keinen Vertrauen in Boris Johnson als Parteichef.
Und dann, die haben dieses Punkt dann am sechsten Juni mit dem ähm äh sechsten Juli,
6. Juni, sorry, ähm äh dieses Punkt erreicht mit den mit den Briefen und danach hat dann Boris Johnson dieses Misstrauensvotum,
damals dann überlebt. Aber der war dann danach.
Nicht besonders.
Besonders stark für ihn, ja. Der hat mit 2hundert11 so hundertachtundvierzig Stimmen,
damals dieses dieses Misstrauensvotum das dann überlebt und das wird dann sehr wichtig, dass es gab dann eine Mehrheit von den sogenannten so so die Hinterbänkler, also die, die,
keine Regierungsarmt haben, also keine Ministers oder Staatssekretären, die haben,
Eine Mehrheit der Hinterbänke waren schon gegen Boris Johnson. Also das war dann kein erfreuliches Ergebnis für ihn. Also die waren dann die zwei wichtigsten Dingen. Diese Misstrauensvotum, wo er nicht enormen Unterstützung hat.
Und zweitens dann diese äh diese Nachwahl. Und das dann war dann nicht alles. Es dann kam dann raus am fünften Juli.
Die Situation, die sogenannten ähm ähm Quiz
Also das waren dann Vorwürfe, dass diese Abgeordnete, also der war bis den 7. Juli, sogenannten
Depity Chief Wape. Also das ist der stellvertretende sage ich so,
Typ, der für Einigkeit innerhalb der Fraktion zuständig ist, ist ein Grip und der war der stellvertretend, also es gibt zwei, die die das dann machen.
Die Peitsche, die für Einigkeit sorg.
Ja genau, genau. Also und äh dann ähm es kamen dann raus ähm ähm der der Typ
ein paar Wochen vorher war offensichtlich betrunken ähm eine große Veranstaltung.
Und es gab dann Vorwürfe zu also sexuelle sexuelles Missbrauch ähm dass er dann äh gegenüber zwei anderen Abgeordneten ähm ja also,
nicht sich nicht korrekt verhalten hat und dann kam eine Diskussion, also,
kannte Boris Johnson überhaupt das sein Depety Chief Whip so agierte und am Beginn hat Boris Johnson einfach gesagt.
Nö, das wusste ich nicht. Ja, aber dann eine ehemalige Beamte, ja ähm hat gesagt.
Stimmt nicht. Ich habe selber Boris Johnson von dieses Chris gewarnt.
Schon in zwanzig neunzehn, als Boris Johnson damals Außenminister war,
Und Boris Johnson votet dieses Chris als so als Staatssekretär im Außenminister äh haben und ich habe ihm schon damals gewarnt, dass damals war es auch
also Vorwürfe so eine Art sexuelle sexuelles Missbrauchs gegen dieses Chris.
Also das stimmt nicht, dass Boris irgendeiner keine Ahnung hatte.
Wir haben ihn mehrmals informiert. Also grob, das ist eine Lüge. Und das war dann, wie wir Menschen sagen, strolle,
the come is back. Also dann zwei ähm ähm Ministers haben dann entschieden dann also Javid der der,
äh Gesundheitsminister und Synac der der Finanzminister. Die beiden sind so getreten. Insgesamt über 40 andere so Ministers und Staatssekretäre und und Junior Ministers sind auch gleichzeitig alle ähm ähm sind dann zurückgetreten.
Im BBC gab es sogar in so einen so einen Counter, der.
Ja genau.
Bilde von alle diese Menschen, so alles so aufgelistet ja also äh diese so Junior Minister, so soll sein den also niemand kannte, wer diese Leute waren. Also auf den Newsticker, ja sonst noch jemanden liegen, wo es so rückt,
Ähm einige mindestens haben doch dann versucht Boris äh Boris zu zu warnen, inklusive Michael Gove und Johnson hast du gesagt, hey nee also danke für die Warnung, aber du bist jetzt gefeuert. Äh also was war ähm,
Und der hat dann einige neue Leute in in sein Team äh reingeholt
Er hat eine neue ähm Bildungsministerin Michael Donulen äh in ins Team reingeholt. Sie war insgesamt 36 Stunden im Arm, bevor sie selber gesagt hat, hey Boris, du musst selber jetzt zurücktreten.
Also er stand dann unter richtig viel Druck und hat dann doch am am am siebten ähm ähm äh siebten Juli ist er dann äh so getreten.
Das Problem ist, er bleibt im Amt als als Premierminister und das beste mindestens bis dem fünften,
ähm äh September. Ähm also er will natürlich sein sein großes ähm ähm Wedding Party,
in den offiziellen Residenz im Sommer noch noch machen können. Äh ernst, ja. Also das ist eins von den Begründungen, warum er da dann ähm äh dann bleiben will. Weil er hat Carrie verheiratet während Corona.
Hat nie so den den ähm äh Heiratsfans nie gehabt und die das veranstalten die im Sommer jetzt in Tschechien, also den offiziellen ähm ähm Residenz der der Premierminister ist.
Dann am Ende doch endgültig dann erste Hälfte von September dann endgültig raus. Aber das ist was dann
zu den am Ende doch Süden Sturz führte. Also nicht nur
Partygate, sondern diese beiden Verluste in den in den in den ähm Nachwahlen und dann dieses dieses so Skandal um Chris.
So, jetzt ist er also so gut wie weg, sagen wir's mal so. Es war,
also es sieht zumindest irreversibel aus durch, das das wird dann erstmal gewesen sein mit Boris Johnson und da kann man irgendwie äh Großbritannien nur dazu gratulieren, weil ich glaube niemand hat.
So viel dafür getan die Meinungen äh die der Rest der Welt über hatte äh in in Mitleidenschaft zu ziehen.
Wie Boris Johnson, das war halt einfach äh nicht mehr zu ertragen.
Ja. Aber Vorsicht.
Es könnte noch schlimmer werden.
Geht immer, ja. Nee, nee, ähm aber ganz ehrlich, also ähm es gibt jetzt noch im Rennen 6 Kandidierenden für den Parteivorsitz.
Also Stand äh heute äh Datum haben wir noch nicht gesagt. Heute ist der äh Donnerstag, der vierzehnte Juli 2zwanzig und äh schon heute Abend könnte das schon wieder anders.
Es dann nur noch fünf. Äh also.
Eine kurze Erklärung, wie wählt man einen einen neuen Parteichef bei den Konservativen?
Zuerst in Runden und den Abgeordneten. Ja, also es gab,
am Beginn oh es gab Gerüchte vom noch mehr Kandidierenden aber es gingen acht,
Kandidierenden im Rennen. Es sind heute nur noch sechs und heute Abend wird's dann nur noch fünf. Also die machen dann eine Runde, wenn dein Mann brauchte am Beginn,
30 Abgeordneten und stürzen von 30 Abgeordneten um überhaupt noch ins Rennen zu bleiben,
Dann waren schon zwei Jeremy Hunt, der gegen Boris Johnson verloren hat, schon zwanzig neun1. Er war dann an an in diese erste Runde, ist er gescheitert diesmal. Also der bis vorletzte Woche,
äh ähm Bildungsminister und dem jetzigen Finanzminister, also der ist auch schon raus.
Das bedeutet, wir haben heute den heutigen Stand ist, wir haben sechs Kandidierende noch im Rennen. Wir haben den ehemaligen Finanzminister Sunac,
den jetzigen Außenministerin.
Eine ehemalige Verteidigungsministerin und den jetzigen Handels
sie noch oder ist sie auch zurückgetreten? Ich weiß nicht, ist egal. Äh ähm und dann drei so eher Außenseiter,
Kemmi Bade noch. Sie war bis vor Kurzem Ministerin für Local Government. Ähm die
Generalchefanwältin, unsere Journey General der Regierung Swille Brevin und den Vorsitzende der Außenausschuss im House of Comments
Tom also die sind dann die sechs, die dann im Rennen sind. Was auf Mai aus meiner Sicht
in den jetzigen Punkt wir erreichen. Also die die Abgeordneten wählen ja nur die Abgeordneten,
um die die Liste an kandidierenden
auf zwei zu reduzieren. Ja, so wir sind jetzt sechs, heute Abend wird's fünf bis irgendwann nächste Woche wird's dann nur noch zwei. Und diese zwei gehen dann an den
Urwahl und Mitglieder der konservativen Partei und es wird dann bekannt gegeben am fünften.
Ähm äh September wer dann gewonnen hat. Und bei dieser Uhrwahl,
eine Beteiligung so ein per Post dann für die Mitglieder der konservativen Partei dann
möglich. Also aus meiner Sicht sind drei von den sechs, die noch im Rennen sind, haben durchaus gute Chancen. Die sind dann Synak, der ehemalige Finanzminister Just, dem jetzigen Außenministerin.
Und Motor und die äh ehemalige Verteidigungsministerin, also die sind die drei, die dann die besten äh die die besten Chancen haben.
Schauen wir doch mal auf die.
Auf die 3 und äh welche Rolle sie denn bisher äh gespielt haben, mal vorausgesetzt dein Gefühl drückt dich äh nicht. Also äh und äh Lizz Jas haben auf jeden Fall den Vorteil, dass sie,
in den letzten Monaten oder letzten paar Jahren sehr viel mehr in der Öffentlichkeit standen und natürlich da ein ganz anderes.
Aber nicht immer nach äh positiv, ja ähm aber ein bisschen schon ja ähm nee also also grundsätzlich.
Zunach ist am bekanntesten, der war auch sehr wichtig bei den konservativen für den EU-Austritt. Also.
Der ist im seinem Herzen, so eine Art.
Small state tori. Ja so der will grundsätzlich Steuerlast reduzieren, ist Pro Business sieht noch eine sehr wichtige Rolle des London City. Was ergibt,
Als Finanzminister war etwas anders. Also man steht,
der unter Druck wegen der Coronakrise, zum Teil auch Wegen, den den EU-Austritt. Er musste dann steuern dann
erhören, um überhaupt die Kosten des Staates sowieso überdecken.
Ähm also ist es dann fraglich, was was ist so dem richtigen Regie Szenarc? Er hatte auch eine Reihe von.
So sage ich so Skandalen,
Es war dann bekannt, dass die Frau von Synac, die sehr reich ist. Ist ja auch eine eine sehr reiche indische Familie, hat
Jahrelang kein Steuer in Großbritannien,
bezahlt ist so eine Art in in in Großbritannien. Und dass das selber jahrelang, das wollte ich von aus auch einen amerikanischen Pass und einen amerikanischen Green Card hatte und das war jahrelang dann
nicht bekannt, dass er dass er das das hatte. Also man hat immer den Eindruck ist.
Irgendwie seine komplette Laufbahn war für ihn irgendwie sehr simpel, ja? Also er.
Er muss nie wirklich kämpfen. Er war nie unter politisches Druck. Er ist selber so reich, dass sie Krieg gebt gibt den Eindruck, dass er versteht,
Sage ich so, die normalen Menschen nicht
irgendwie, ja? Ich verstehe, was sie meint, also er macht so ein Bild, so vorne Tankstelle, ja mit einem kleinen Auto. Niemand glaubt daran, dass er selber ein klein Hunde oder ein Tier oder so äh ähm fährt, ja? Also,
Es fehlt ihm dann eine Art,
zu den Burger. Also was das ist Boris immer ziemlich gut gelungen. Ja also der ist aus der Britische Elite aber hatte einen sehr.
Lustigen Umgang mit aller Arten von Menschen. Also diese so personal touch hat so eine auf keinen Fall.
Er ist intellektuell sehr klug, kann ich auch behaupten, ja? Ich.
Eine ist auch ziemlich lustig, ja. Ich fahre auf der Universität mit Synac. Ich erinnere mich überhaupt nicht an ihm, ob er ob wir an genau dem gleichen Kurs, an die gleichen genau die gleiche Universität war, ist ziemlich lustig. Ich habe ich habe ihm überhaupt nicht in Erinnerung.
Ähm vielleicht hat er einfach ähm wenige Studentenpolitik, als ich da gemacht damals äh äh damals in Oxland, aber es ist ziemlich lustig. Ähm
Aber gut ähm dann die anderen kandidieren. Also war dann bei der Brexit Referendum für einen Verbleib in der EU?
Ähm hat dann sehr schnell.
Verstanden im Moment. Also die konservative Partei ist dann jetzt vollkommen für einen harten Austritt, hat sich selber dann
immer mehr als so Liebling der der Partei positioniert in alle Sachen Brexit ja so einfach so ich bin jetzt überzeugte Brexiteer
Ähm sie ist oder gibt den Eindruck auch als Außenministerin, dass sie.
Nicht immer sehr klug ist oder nicht immer sehr ernst. Sie ist immer jemand so für so einen netten Instagram Bild statt eine eine so ordentliche.
Diskussion oder oder man kriegt den Eindruck, dass.
Von Sommunikation und den Medien vorangetrieben, nicht an eine grundsätzliche Interesse an den,
Felder selber. Ähm aber sie ist.
Ziemlich bekannt, ja? Also es könnte dann doch noch helfen und weil sie einen Schritt weiter vom
dem Zentrum des Regierungs Boris Johnson war. Sie hat zum Beispiel keine Strafe gekriegt während den ganzen Partygate. Auch Sona Cat musste eine ähm ähm eine Strafe bezahlen.
Mhm.
Und sie ist, muss man sagen, vom so von Hintergrund her etwas normaler. Ja, sie hat aus Kassenprüferinnen gearbeitet.
Aha, so ein paar hat ein paar Gerüchte gehabt, dass sie hat ein paar Affären mit anderen Abgeordneten. Ja, aber das ist
Das gehört zu den Alltag bei den konservativen Partei so
ja also vielleicht hat sie wird sie wenige also die wenige Kontroverse oder eine andere persönliche Kontroverse aus als Szenac.
Aber sie war auch als Außenminister fast. Anderthalb Jahren im Amt, ja. Synagogen war auch nicht so lange Finanzminister, also die hatten beiden.
Hörenrrangigen Rollen, aber nicht seit so irre lang. Also die sind beide ziemlich auch ziemlich unerfahren. Und wenn die beide sehr unerfahren, sie müssen erfahren sind, dann dann die Situation für Motor und ist,
unglaublich. Also es war seit Jahrzehnten der Fall, dass fast keine Premierminister mit Ministers Großbritanniens hat nie eins von den drei Hauptämten des Landes.
Die anderen Hauptämten nicht nie gehabt, also ähm ähm Außenminister, Finanzminister oder Innenminister diese drei Rollen hatten Mode und Nie. Sie war ein paar Jahre lang Verteidigungsministerin.
Aber sie ist eine ziemlich interessante Mischung aus.
So alt und modern irgendwie bei der Partei. So sie ist in Sachen Sozialpolitik ziemlich liberal.
Ähm also ein bisschen mehr so auf der David Cameron Linie, dass dass die konservative Partei muss grundsätzlich
die so moderne Großbritanniens irgendwie akzeptieren
Aber auf der anderen Seite, sie war für ein EU-Austritt. Sie will die Steuerlast auf dem äh auf der Bevölkerung senken. Die Details, wie sie das tut.
Sagen sie nicht so ganz. Ähm also das ist dann eine ziemlich interessante Mischung, aber wir,
kennen sehr, sehr wenig über Mord
Aber es kam jetzt in den letzten paar Tagen die ersten Meinungsumfragen heraus und Meinungsumfragen nicht unter dem gesamten Bewölkung, sondern unter Parteimitglieder der künstlerischen Partei und und alle gehen jetzt davon aus, dass wenn sie.
Dann,
wenn es und gelingt in die letzte Runde zu kommen, also diese diese Urwahl unter Parteimitglieder, sie kann gegen Truss und auch gegen Synac,
in diese Urwahl dann gewinnen. Aber natürlich was
möglich ist. Es ist könnte irgendeinen Skandal geben oder irgendeine Entdeckung und man könnte sich dann einfach unter Druck setzen während diese Ulm-Wahlprozedere und irgendwas könnte dann
doch sehr schief gehen und sie könnte dann schnell irgendwie scheitern. Also das ist nicht
unmöglich, ja? Aber meine Vermutung wäre, nach dem jetzigen Stand, dass sie hat die besten Chancen.
Stunt Forsnack und Schuss die noch doch noch Chancen haben und die anderen drei sind dann äh bleiben dann immer noch Außenseiten noch und und.
Wie läuft das nochmal genau ab? Also es gibt jetzt diese Vorauswahl, die wird aber jetzt nicht von der ganzen Partei.
Sondern nur unter Abgeordneten.
Oder den Abgeordneten. So, das heißt, die müssen dann Support äh äh bekommen und dann wird halt einer nach dem anderen rausgenommen. Ist ja eigentlich so, der Demokratie äh spezifischen Prinzipien, mal abgesehen davon, dass es jetzt nur die Abgeordneten sind und dann
ist es natürlich nicht
wirklich demokratisch oder zumindest nimmt es nicht alle äh Parteimitglieder äh äh mit, aber so vom Prozedere her verhindert man halt so erstmal so dieses Screenshat äh Red Check äh Problem, das sozusagen irgendjemand durchkommt. Nur äh weil die anderen sich
den anderen nicht äh einigen.
Dieses Problem hatte die Labour Partei, also Jeremy Coben war unter den Parteimitglieder,
Eine Weile lang beliebt, aber unter den Abgeordneten gehasst. Ja, also die diese Prozedere innerhalb der konstruktiven Partei ist genau dieses Problematik.
Zu verhindern. Also man brauche nach dem Regeln da eine gewisse Unterstützung unter dem
Abgeordneten, mit denen man am jeden Tag arbeiten muss und eine gewisse Unterstützung unter den Parteimitgliedern. So das ist genau den Grund, warum.
So Doppelprozedere ausgedacht habe.
Genau, das heißt, man nimmt erstmal so die beiden, auf die sich im Prinzip des Abgeordnetenhaus in irgendeiner Form oder die Abgeordneten Tutorials ähm,
Sich einigen könnten und dann übernimmt es sozusagen das Parteivolk, dann gibt es diese Urwahl und dann entscheidet halt äh wer mehr Stimmen bekommen hat.
Und das wird dann im September ähm spätestens durch sein oder kann es sein, dass es schneller geht, also.
Nur man könnte man könnte die Situation erleben,
Wie es mit Theresa May ausgegangen ist. Also da war dann Theresa May in diese Urwahl zuletzt zwei zusammen mit Andrea Lenzom damals und letztem.
Es dann so hochgetreten. Ja, sie war unter so viel Druck, dass sie gesagt ich kann nicht mehr, ich trete zurück und dann warnt Theresa May dann automatisch.
Partei äh Parteivorsitzenden.
Da kam es nie zu.
Kam es nie so oval. Ähm also
aber das mochten die Parteimitglieder natürlich nicht, also die wollen das diesmal dann auch vermeiden. Also ich gehe davon aus, dass Johnson bleibe dann im Abend bis bis dem 5. September.
Okay, aber dann.
Und dann dann mit eine Urwahl und dann die die die Situation wird dann dieses Urwald dann geklärt und eine deinen neuen Premierminister wird dann im Abend sein äh dann kurz danach.
Es wird jetzt gesetzgeberisch ohnehin nicht mehr viel funktionieren, weil jetzt äh Sommerpause ist et cetera.
Genau. Ja und die die die Ministeriarollen sind voll mit so zu total hoffnungslosen Ahnungslosen Idioten, dass äh dass die kriegen auch gar nicht durch. Also ähm.
Das heißt UK liegt dir jetzt erstmal brach für die nächsten zwei.
Ja genau, aber sie haben sich so, es ist so echt so,
idiotische Abgeordnete. Sie ist jetzt eben an irgendeinem ministeriaalabend und ähm und dann äh ein paar Leute Street gekommen ist ähm ähm
haben so so viele Leute gelacht, sie hat dann die Leute, die da vor einfach so den Mittelfinger ähm äh gezeigt. Ach so Moment mal, also das ist kein Verhalten für für ein Minister.
Ohne also ähm und ja also die Situation wird.
Wird schwierig in den nächsten Monaten bis Boys Johnson dann raus ist. Also.
Großbritannien steht jetzt und du richtig viel Druck wegen Corona. Ja, so nach den jetzigen
ähm stammt, haben eins von 15 Menschen in Großbritannien derzeit. Den coronavirus ähm also ähm den den Gesundheitswesen ist unter richtig viel Druck
Ähm also wenn irgendwas da wirklich schief geht, ist die Regierung von Boris Johnson dann überhaupt in der Lage.
Irgendwie so reagieren. Ähm also das ist nicht selbstverständlich
ja ähm und es war nicht nötig solange zu brauchen für für dieses Urwahl. Man kriegt das innerhalb von sechs Wochen hin,
tun die aber nicht, weil Boris Johnson hat gesagt, ich will mam bleiben bis September und das haben die dann in äh komischerweise dann akzeptiert, ja also das war keine gute Entscheidung, aus meiner Sicht für die Konzepte, aber gut.
Warum gelingt es den britischen Opposition nicht, aus dieser Situation in irgendeiner Form Kapital zu schlagen? Weil man hat ja nicht, also meine gut, sie haben jetzt ein paar äh äh gewonnen oder so, aber das jetzt wirklich so die offene Systemfrage gestellt wird, wollen wir jetzt überhaupt noch mit den Torries weitermachen oder nicht?
Ich meine
wären jetzt Wahlen, dann säh es wahrscheinlich gar nicht gut aus für die Torries, aber es ist ja auch nicht so, dass es irgendeinen Hype äh geben würde, um Kirstdama oder so etwas.
Ja, aber der ist okay, die.
Laber ist jetzt 7 oder 8 Prozent vor der Konservativen in den Meinungsumfragen, also mit so einem Vorsprung, gewinnt man.
Nicht so locker, aber geben wir schon eine Unterauswahl. Ähm also.
Starma hat einfach Angst. Der ist als Person vorsichtig. Der will nicht so.
Er ist so risikoervers.
Und äh erwartet, bis die Konservativen so selbe stürzen. Ja, er ist nicht so wirklich jemandem für.
Eine sehr klare Linie oder es sieht nicht immer so ähm äh sehr.
Es sieht Möglichkeiten nicht, ja ähm und wenn man sieht, wie schwierig das war, so,
zehn Jahre lang für die Label Partei in die Diskussion in den britischen Medien. Vielleicht hat er recht, dass er dann so vorsichtig vorangeht. Ja vielleicht ist es einfach der Fall, dass,
kann dieses komplette System nicht ändern vor die selber an der Macht kommen.
Und was dann so problematisch war unter unter Labour Vorgänge wie Turny Blayer oder Golden Brown ist.
Das Leben dann dann an die Macht gekommen ist, die haben dann ziemlich wenig an dieses Machtstrukturen
selber geändert. Ja, aber das ist diese Vorgehensweise von von Starma. Also seine Position ist parteiinten ziemlich stark, in die Meinungsumfragen ziemlich stark, aber er versucht nicht so wirklich.
Diese so komplette Problematik des britischen Status Staates zu ändern. Er redet nie um Brexit.
Azard, wir wollen unsere eigene Variante vom Brexit, was dann besser funktionieren wird als aus den die Version von den Konservativen. Das ist einen kompletten Widerspruch, weil Wirtschaftlichkeit kann
aller Arten von Brexit nicht wirklich funktionieren, entweder politisch oder wirtschaftlich, akzeptiert er nicht. Also er er ist zu sehr nervös in seinem Verhalten, äh aber,
kann das hauptwegs verstehen, muss ich sagen.
Ja, äh es gibt einfach so viele Probleme in Großbritannien. Ja, also er muss erstens an der Macht kommen und er sieht, und das kann ich auch irgendwie verstehen, er sieht einen Weg.
So das doch hinzukriegen.
Ähm und weil es wird eine Unterhauswahl geben spätestens 2024 aber höchstwahrscheinlich schon nächstes Jahr.
Äh sieht dann ein Weg dann an der doch noch an der Macht zu kommen.
Warum denkst du, dass nächstes Jahr schon eine Wahl ist.
Weil das die Wahl von Boris Johnson ähm fand Dezember.
Ähm wie habe ich das richtig kakiert? Also das war der zwanzigneunzehn.
Also es muss dann spätestens nee, kann sein, es könnte Sommer zwanzig vierundzwanzig so. Nun
Normalerweise finden Wahlen in Großbritannien so im späten Frühling oder Frühsommer statt.
Ja? Aber dieses Fall von Boris Johnson fand die Dezember statt wegen den den damaligen äh politische Krise in Großbritannien. Also ich gehe davon aus, dass er wird nicht bis Dezember,
Ein Nachfolger von Johnson wird nicht bis September
Dezember zwanzig24 warten und macht das ein bisschen früher, so im Sommer 2024 oder vielleicht schon nächstes Jahr. Es hängt davon ab, wie sähe dann den.
Die Situation,
dann für eine Regierung aus. Könnt die dann doch noch regieren oder brauchen die dann eine gewisse Unterstützung, ja? Also dass dieses die Tradition Wahlen,
nach vorne zu schieben
Schon in Großbritannien. Also es ist nicht ausgeschlossen, dass das könnte schon nächstes Jahr stattfinden. Aber so ich habe das falsch kalkuliert. Dezember aus meiner Sicht, Dezember 2024 wird es nicht sein, obwohl das juristisch möglich sei.
Ich gehe davon aus, es wird dann Sommer zwanzig vierundzwanzig, also jetzt in zwei Jahren.
Ähm die.
Inneren Konflikte schließen ja und ich meine wir reden ja auch immer noch irgendwie über,
Brexit. Das ist ja hier so ein bisschen unser äh unser Untertitel oder Übertitel, wie auch immer. Ähm
weil schon all das worüber wir jetzt reden, mehr oder weniger ja so einen Ripple-Effekt von von diesem Ereignis äh noch ist. Ganz stark ist das natürlich zu merken in
Schottland
Und haben wir jetzt noch überhaupt nicht äh geredet. Hatten wir aber früher immer mal wieder erwähnt, weil es ja immer noch diese Bestrebungen gibt zu einem Unabhängigkeit, zu einem weiteren Unabhängigkeitsreferendum vorangetrieben von
der Premierministerin Nicola Störgun, da hat sie ja auch wieder einen neuen Schritt
gemacht und jetzt glaube ich sogar offiziell einen Antrag gestellt, dass ein solches weiteres Referendum nächstes Jahr?
Ja am 19. Oktober nächstes Jahr stattfinden soll die Frage ist.
Oder wie das juristisch sei. Wenn wir erinnern uns an der Situation zwanzig vierzehn.
Damals hat es eine Einigung gegeben zwischen David Cameron und die SNP.
Dann das.
Die hat so akzeptiert, dass so eine Referendum stattfinden kann. Und London wäre dann bereit, das Ergebnis zu akzeptieren. Das ist jetzt nicht.
Das sieht so aus, es sei nicht der Fall, dass London erlaube dann dieses Volksabstimmung nicht,
Die Frage ist dann, und es ist immer noch umstritten, ist es überhaupt juristisch möglich, dass sie Schotten entscheiden, alleine so was dann zu machen?
Ja und dann, das ist dann die große Frage für Herbst dieses Jahr? Und wie,
Reagieren dann die zukünftigen Parteichefs der konservativen Partei, also eine zukünftige Premierminister.
Habe dieses Idee der Schorten, dann noch ein Volksabstimmung äh da
zu machen. Und das wissen wir nicht. Einige von den Kandidieren haben schon gesagt, nein, wir erlauben keinen keinen weiteren schottischen,
Volksabstimmung. Manche anderen vielleicht doch Tugenden ja obwohl ich gehe davon aus, dass er nicht gewinnt. Sind
etwas offen, ne, aber nicht offiziell offen. Vielleicht ein bisschen etwas offener für für ein ähm äh einen weiteren Volksabstimmung. Ach so
Ich habe ja Angst, dass es könnte alles so eine Art Situation in Katalonien dann führen, wo dann London, den Volksabstimmung nicht, die Schotten führen das sowieso durch als Art
ähm so Meinungsbild.
Und dann herrsche dann danach noch schlechtere ähm Verhältnisse zwischen Schottland und ähm.
Und London. Äh also das ist dem dem jetzigen Stand. Es ist dann nicht klar.
Ob dieses Volksabstimmungen stattfinden kann und wenn ja und welchen juristischen Bedingungen.
Ich meine, was würde denn passieren, wenn jetzt der oder die neue Premierministerin und die Torries damit halt da einfach sagen so, nö, machen wir nicht.
Würde ja dann sozusagen auch nicht unbedingt das Verhältnis zwischen Schottland und äh England verbessern.
Natürlich und dann das das ist irgendwie genau was Nicholes Sterging irgendwie will.
Sie sagt, hey Moment mal so, wir wollen ein ein Volksabstimmung. Was,
Lohn uns versprochen hat, das letzte Mal, also mir mehr macht, wenn ihr in der Union bleibt, das,
Kam nie zustande, dass die damalige Argumentation
wir müssen zusammen bleiben, damit wir alle in der EU bleiben können, ja? Das kam auch nicht zustande. Also das bedeutet, ich kann einfach nicht weitergehen. Also das das
Hill, das hilft dann natürlich ähm um dann dieses Argument für einen unabhängigen Schottland,
zu machen. Es hilft natürlich nicht mit, wie man das tut, wenn es keine klare juristische Weg dahin gibt
Und natürlich, man blickt auch nach Nordirland und sagt, hey Moment mal so, wie lösen wir die die die ganze Probleme an der
English schottische Grenze, wenn Schottland dann die EU dann beitreten will
Äh natürlich gibt's auch dann Probleme mit Grenzübergängen und natürlich die die schottische Wirtschaft ist noch tiefer mit.
Dem Brest Kurs Großbritannien sind als Notelland Jevar, also die die Lieferketten in Nuria waren schon ein bisschen separater als als die in in Schottland.
Es gibt eine Riesenreihe von Problemen die die dann zu zu lösen sind. Aber ich sehe.
Nicht unbedingt irgendeine friedliche.
Ich meine nicht Krieg, ja aber in einer eine friedliche politische Lösung hier, ja. Vielleicht mit Tügendart als Parteichef der konservativen wäre so was möglich,
Vielleicht könnte er dann mehr oder weniger die Linie von Cameron weiterhin unterstützen und für dann ein bisschen mehr Ruhe äh dann sorgen. Aber mit Le Strass,
Ja, also ähm sie sie so ein sie ist auch sehr kämpferisch in in wie sie agiert. Motor und auch ja also ähm Mode und hat auch eine
ähm so eine persönliche Geschichte bei den ähm bei den
Royal Navy und Royal Navy hat viele Stationen in Schottland, also sie lehnt eine Volksabstimmung ab. Sunac aus meiner Sicht hat,
wenig Interesse an Schottland. Sie ist nicht im wirtschaftlich wichtigsten Teil von Großbritannien. Ja, also hat er.
Wenig Bock sich mit dieses komplette Themenfan zu beschäftigen. Also ich gehe davon aus, dass
wir werden diese keine Lösung haben bis Herbst, das ist ja klar ähm und und von den drei so führenden Kandidierenden für den Parteivorsitz. Ähm da habe ich keine große Hoffnung, dass die auch dieses dieses Problem da lösen.
Also es ist erstmal durchaus wahrscheinlich, dass es abgelehnt werden wird. Ja. Weil sie müssen sich.
Und dann ist Fürth dann sehr spannend im im Winter dieses Jahr.
Genau und das ist auch die Frage, welche welche Hebel eigentlich äh Schottland hat. Weil ich meine, sie sind sie können mit nichts wirklich groß Druck machen, oder?
Ja, aber die die Chance.
Gäbe es dann so eine Art Indicitive Referendum auszuführen. Und wenn die das machen und das mit dann ein Mehrheit für den Austritt, ja, das das übt dann schon Druck auf London aus.
Wäre das legal.
Ja, wenn ich's nicht juristisch bindend sei, ja, aber eine eine Art wir machen eine Art, wir nennen das keinen Volksabstimmung, so eine Art
Umfrage, Poberumfrage, irgendwas. Wäre es wäre es juristisch möglich, ja.
Ja aber dann mal London könnte einfach dann danach sagen, he nee, sorry, das lehnen wir ab. Ja und dann wo landet man? Ja, also es ist nicht nicht.
Erkannt. Ähm.
Aber das ist aus meiner Sicht die die richtigen wohin alles zur Zeit dann steuert. Aber natürlich also es gibt.
Es gibt Konflikte überall, ja, also politisches Konflikt, nicht so, so, so äh
Krieg, ja? Ähm es gibt diese Konflikte in Nordirland, es gibt eine mögliche Konflikt in Schottland
Es gibt Konflikte zwischen die Regierungsebenen in England, ja, weil viele viele von den lokalen Regionen sind fast pleite wegen so geringen Steuereinnahmen.
Ähm es gibt den bestehenden Konflikt mit der EU, ja? Es ist man hat den Eindruck, dass die jetzige Regierung, die es herrscht Konflikt.
Überall mit allen. Ja und das einfach so Gutes regieren.
Spielt keine Rolle mehr und dann diese diese mögliche Konflikte mit Schottland ist, noch dann den den neusten Beweis davon.
Dass man die Option, dass man Kehre so eine Art ordentlich regiertes Großbritannien zurück.
Wo man versucht, diese Problemen zu mindern, zu beruhigen, zu irgendwie das alles wird nach einem ordentlichen Art und Weise regiert,
Ich habe ja keine Hoffnung, dass dass sowas passieren wird in den nächsten paar Jahren. Ja, es ist nicht mehr nur Brexit, also Brexit führte dann so eine eine komplette Art zur Staatskrise.
Ist Großbritannien überhaupt in der Lage ordentlich regieren zu werden, eine andere Beispiel zur Zeit,
Reisepässe. Es gibt Nomen, Verzögerungen, in die Ausstellung von Reisepässe in Großbritannien. Also viele wollen im im Urlaub reisen, kriegen keine neue Reisepässe mehr, ja? Und haben Wartezeiten von sechs Monaten, um meine Reisepass zu kriegen.
So auch ja oder oder Erneuerung.
Berliner Verhältnisse.
Ja, ja, ja, nur schlimmer, ja oder oder auch ähm ähm aber alles ist zentralisiert in Großbritannien. Es gibt sogar eine zentrale Ausschreibungsbehörde. Die haben die Anzahl an.
Ähm an Beamen dort so reduziert
sie nicht mehr in der Lage sind, das das richtig zu machen. Oder bei der Ausstellung von einem von Führerscheine gibt's auch enorme Verzögerungen
und dann die Kandidierenden für den Parteivorsitzender. Ja, wir haben weit zu viele weit zu viel Bürokratie in Großbritannien. Wir müssen die Anzahl an Beamten noch reduzieren. Also Moment mal, also
des kompletten Service ist schon am Boden. Ja wenn man das noch mehr reduziert, ist die Lage noch ernster. Ja, also das ist so,
Realitätsfern, die die komplette Diskussion.
Am besten noch alles privatisieren, ne.
Ja aber aber aber dann das kostet ja was natürlich dann Beginn, ja? Haben die auch nicht kapiert. Ähm also selber, also ich ich.
Ich beobachte das dann von fern. Ja, aber wenn ich die Rede, wenn mein Vater zu dem Thema ach so, das die ist so.
Sieht keine Verbesserung in Sicht, ja. Äh ist vollkommen deformiert, ne.
Ja und das wäre jetzt so ein bisschen meine letzte Frage. Was passiert eigentlich mit der britischen Gesellschaft? Ich meine, sind die alle nach wie vor so sehr.
Durch diese Spaltung des Brexits äh so äh verblendet, dass das alles immer noch so ein Partisanenkrieg ist. Äh,
und gibt's da keine Möglichkeit, dass ich da einfach auch mal in der Bevölkerung einfach einen Widerstand regt, der sagt
Leute, wir haben uns jetzt hier diese Clownshow irgendwie ein paar Jahre angeschaut. Es geht irgendwo nirgendwo voran.
Aber wer wer wäre bereit so eine,
Widerstand zu organisieren, ja. Es gab ja schon ein bisschen unter unsere den Gewerkschaften. Es gab diverse Bahnstreiks in Großbritannien in letzter Zeit. Also vielleicht sind die Gewerkschaften halbwegs in einer Situation, dass das organisieren.
Aber Fisch steht die britische Gesellschaft, diese komplette Situation. Ich bin,
nicht mehr so sicher, ja? Also,
es ist alles so im Blick und also wenn man wirft ein Blick von Großbritannien zu anderen Ländern der EU. Man kann so sehen, hey Moment, also da in anderen Länder ist es vielleicht kein Paradies in Frankreich oder ohne Deutschen, aber die meisten grundsätzlichen Dingen
funktionieren doch noch besser dort als als in Großbritannien. Ähm also das bedeutet äh dieses Verständnis,
also wie schief das gerade geht ja ist das ist irgendwie auch verloren gegangen. Also ich.
Siegentuch suchen Riesenproteste kommen könnte oder so. Ist vielleicht nicht unmöglich, aber das halte ich für ziemlich unwahrscheinlich.
Aber ist das dann nicht auch ein Problem wiederum der medialen Landschaft, dass die das nicht ausreichend reflektiert?
Genau und und auch der BBC reflektiert das nicht. Ja ähm natürlich hat man hat eine Art Diskussion um diesen Themen in Daily Mail oder Daily Miro und und The Guardian aber.
Versteht die Bewölkung wie ernst die jetzige Situation ist? Ja dann bin ich nicht.
So überzeugt. Ja ähm.
Ja und und und Label organisiert diese Opposition nicht. Die Liberalen sind zu klein, die Schotten wollen weg. Äh Nordirland hat so schon eine eigene Reihe an einen problematischen Fällen.
Es gibt die ehemalige Supermain-Bewegungen, aber man will nicht mal wieder doch noch einmal so den umstrittenen Brexit dann ähm äh erkämpfen.
Es gibt andere Leute, die dann haben einfach eine Hoffnung auch, hey Moment mal, so kann dann kein Widerstand oder so. Man hofft auf deine Nachfolge von Bruce Johnson. Es kann nicht schlimmer sein als Boris Johnson, also da haben wir schon ein bisschen,
ein bisschen die Wände, also da sehen wir dann vielleicht ein Weg daraus.
Ja ähm ja aber aber ein Riesenaufstand warte ich nicht nein.
Nicht unbedingt das Land der der Straßenproteste, ich meine das was so gegen Bre.
Straßenproteste stürzt du zum Beispiel Margare äh neunzehn neunzig, ja? So die wegen diese und die die die Steuerreformen, ja? Also es
kam ein paar Mal zustande, aber in den letzten Jahren dann dann nicht, aber natürlich auch so Pretty Portal, also sehr starken Regelungen hineingeführt.
Gegenproteste, ja Protest recht zu begrenzen. Und es gibt natürlich auch wegen wegen diesem ähm ganze Partygate Untersuchung, Vorwürfe, dass die Metropole Police auch selber korrupt sei.
Also die.
Die so die Säulen des britischen schwanken so alle, ja? BBC, königliche Familie, Polizei, Paliment, ähm also und.
Und irgendwie oberflächlich das ganze Ding funktioniert doch noch. Aber hinter den Kulissen ist alles in einem.
Sehr unstabilen Zustand, ja? Man weiß ja nicht, wem kann man doch noch glauben ähm und ähm.
Das macht mir so wütend und traurig, wenn ich wenn ich das dann sehe.
Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Aber ich bin so froh, dass ich nicht da vor nicht mehr da wohne. Ja? Ich das vom Fern zu beobachten ist schon deprimierend genug.
Dass vor Ort da vor Ort zu sein, wenn ich rede mit mit mit Freunden und Verwandten ähm.
Manche von meinen Freunden hier. Ich habe so Politikwissenschaften studiert. Ich kenne viele Leute aus der politischen.
So politische Kreise. Einige von meinen Freunden sagen, wieso wir weg wir können die nicht mehr hören, ja oder nicht mehr lesen. Ja, die haben komplett abgeschaltet, weil das ist dann dem einzigen Weg mit dem alltäglichen Situation umzugehen.
Das ist so so irgendwie.
Kann ich ganz gut verstehen. Ich meine, das ist auch wenn jetzt so die Kriegsnachrichten mal wieder heftig werden und so weiter. Da hat man immer mal wieder so einen Moment, da möchte man einfach nur noch den Kopf unter die Decke stecken und sagen so, lala ich kriege davon gar nichts mit.
Genau und das ist genau die Situation.
Der Kopf ist unter der Decke. Ja, dann.
Dann das war's. Ja, sehen wir halt mal, aber dann vielleicht ab dem fünften.
Den 5. September sehen wir, ob vielleicht, ja, also ein etwas bisschen optimistisch ist.
Boris Johnson als Person.
War so sehr schwierig für alle Oppositionsparteien. Man wusste nie mit ihm, was will er machen, was ist ihre Realität, was ist eine Lüge, es war alles so alles so durchgemischt.
Alle anderen Kandidierenden sind irgendwie normaler. Ja die sind vielleicht nicht vertrauenswürdiger, aber sie sind alle irgendwie normaler. Also kehrt dann britisches Politik so.
Etwas normalere politischen Themen zurück,
Gesundheitspolitik, Sozialpolitik, Fiskalpolitik, ein bisschen so normalere Außenpolitik.
Ja, da bestehe schon eine Möglichkeit, ja. Ob es zu besseren Ergebnissen führen wird, das weiß ich nicht. Aber Großbritannien, Politik wird ab dem Herbst hoffentlich,
durchaus ein bisschen normaler. Und das ist keine schlechte Sache.
Super positiver Ausblick. Mehr war nicht zu holen, aber immerhin. Die Hoffnung stirbt äh zuletzt und die Queen natürlich. Äh die stimmt so.
Aber wenn die Queen stirbt, dann dann alles bricht auseinander.
Das kann gut sein, aber ich glaube, das erleben wir nicht mehr. Vielen Dank, John.
Alles klar. Und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Dank fürs Zuhören, Leute. Genau, wir hören uns äh.